welcome everybody I'm Chris Kohler for
Wired and today we are headed over to
Smosh games to talk about the biggest
game changing event of 2014 I really was
excited about the announcement of
overwatch Blizzard going into a
territory they haven't really been in
first-person shooter and really kind of
knocking it out of the park from what I
saw
did anybody play it yeah I got the plate
I was playing his Bastion which is this
guy that can transform into a turret you
can't move at all it's a church but he's
got a shield mentioning his wizards
first new IP and 17 yes yes first truly
new literally a game-changing event
because it was a whole new game right I
would say that one of the biggest things
that happened this year was the release
of the Nintendo 3ds XL here's why I see
it well yes it makes a lot easier for my
blind eyes but more importantly as an
adult I never got the 3ds in the first
place because it was too small my hands
are too big but with a Super Smash
coming out first I was like no I need a
3d so you play smash oh hey now there's
this larger one that I can play so now
more adults have 3dsxl
so they can release more games in the
future that appeal not only to kids
gonna be in the older demographic as
well why a 2014 event was minecraft in
Mojang the acquisition of Minecraft it's
interesting because I don't exactly know
where it's going but I know what's going
somewhere with it big news a lot of
people were upset about it a lot of
people are excited about it and I'm
still just kind of in limbo watching to
see when I have one of the most popular
games in the country possibly in the
world yeah and being bought out by
Microsoft for two billion dollars
billion with a beat
dota 2 international championships ti3
the biggest video game tournament in
history reached up to an 11 million
dollar prize pool about two billion not
two billion dollars but this year I
think it was game-changing because they
showed a promo port on ESPN mainstream
television it is the time when video
games have started to become realized as
the biggest form of entertainment and
people are realizing that wow like this
is actually
kind of a sport and so I think we're
going to see more and more of these
games like counter-strike and Starcraft
and all those other games that are
considered esports actually appearing in
mainstream media so I think it's a
pretty big I absolutely think that it is
think that that could impact gaming the
most that happened over the past year is
Facebook's
acquisition of oculus just pumping tons
and tons of money into this tiny startup
so that they can they can really just
like go crazy and like fulfill all of
their dreams and what they want to do
with this incredible virtual reality
headset that's is really it's it's gonna
bring virtual reality back I got oculus
at home and I've got this so far my
favorite thing is just like soaring
around space and I'm like where is this
gonna go I just wanted to just be the
future already and when Facebook take
that took over it I was like okay this
is happening now we're gonna have future
VR world there's a bomb defusal game
that I play called keep talking and
nobody explodes it's amazing like
somebody so somebody outside the oculus
rift just has a manual that tells you
how to defuse the bomb like that's the
kind of awesome stuff we're gonna be
seeing now that like oculus has all of
this like crazy money and can start like
doing because as you said it's a games
problem it's a software problem the
hardware is great now you got a design
for VR so I think that is gonna be the
most impactful thing hey what do you
think the craziest thing is that's
happened in 2014 in video games let us
know in the comments well we've had a
great time talking about the madness
that was 2014 in video gaming here with
the Smosh games crew definitely
subscribe to the wired channel for more
and hey subscribe to Smosh games you
want to see more of these guys thanks
everybody for watching
did you notice that why would you write
it